Nguyên Lời, Să Kura Chi Ma Chin đạo kiêu xô miền năm tế tục viên nhận được kun trang mạnh,
bởi khu thói và cho bộ bất cao tới 1 phải 1 kilometh,
ngoại đậm xa càng của Nú Lời khiến cho bộ dài xuống nhiều khu vực.
Thù các tình, các khu xì mà, kương mà một tổ và mì ra giá kì.
Să Kura Chi Ma là một chừng những nỗ lượng hoạt động mạnh nhất định bản,
thường suyên kun trang với tận xuất cao.
Cào cơ quan khi tượng nhận bản, G-Mai.
Chào bộ, tự kết được kun trang đã si chuyển về hú đồng bắt.
Chứ mấy tụng suy chi mất cảnh bảo bà chi năm, yêu cầu hạn chế tiếp cận
và khu vực gần biển nú Lời.
Mì theo dõi xin biển hoạt động của Să Kura Chi Ma được tăng cường,
nhằm đánh giáng Nguy cơ, phas sinh cơ đật kun trang mới chúng tử dành tới.
Chính quyết địa phần cho biết, khiển chứ có báo cáo về tương vong ai thị thải biển nhà cơ,
sau tình trẳng cho bộ dây đặc, đã dân tất viện huy hàng chục trình bai
tại một số xanh bai ở tây năm nhận bản.